the ruling class is not happy that
people are pushing back against these
mandates they're not they don't like
that they don't like it when people tell
them no
and you're seeing this especially in
crooked machine political towns such as
chicago so lori lightfoot who is as
close to a mobster as any
any
mayor currently in office
lori lightfoot is mandating that the
cops all take the fouchyache in chicago
chicago is basically a third world
country
the the rates of violent crime in
chicago are through the roof
and uh so lori lightfoot
is demanding that cops
stay on the job but they've got to take
the fouchy at you so some cops are
saying no you know i think i'm going to
quit if you're going to make me take the
fauchiachi i think i'm just not going to
do it i was just in chicago i was
briefly at o'hare airport i spoke to
some cops there and they were saying
they're looking at 40 to 50
of cops just quitting or retiring you're
just leaving the job because they don't
want to deal with this
so what does lori lightfoot say is this
people exercising their freedom of
choice is this people
you know just exercising their moral
conscience and doing the responsible
thing no
no she calls it an insurrection we
believe that the fop leadership is
trying to foment in a legal workstop it
could shrink pure and simple we've laid
that out in the materials um and we're
not just we're not having that the
contract is clear and it's been known
for a long time
the police unions are not authorized to
strike it's in their collective
bargaining agreement it's a matter of
state law what we've seen from
the fraternal order of police and
particularly the leadership is a lot of
misinformation a lot of half-truths and
frankly flat-out lies in order to induce
an insurrection
and we're not having that it's an
insurrection right right i forgot it's
an insurrection
anything the democrats don't like is an
insurrection
anything they do like is a wonderful
defense of our democracy
so when for instance uh radical leftists
at the encouragement of democrat
politicians up to and including kamala
harris and staffers for joe biden when
they uh you know set uh courthouses on
fire and attack police buildings and
kill dozens of people and steal a bunch
of sneakers during the
blm rides of 2020 that's a defense of
our democracy
kamala harris will bail them out of jail
because of how much they're defending
our democracy but when the horn guy
dances in the capital that's an
insurrection
when
leftists torch chicago and loot and
steal and kill and pillage and burn
that's a defense of our democracy that's
a wonderful thing when cops
don't want to inject themselves with an
experimental drug and so they very
peaceably just decide to retire that's
an insurrection the democrats are going
to do they already are doing to the word
insurrection
what they did to the word racist the
word racist doesn't mean anything
anymore it may once have meant something
it no longer does
did you know that october is cyber
security awareness month i actually did
not know that because i i like to think
that every month is cyber security
awareness month because i don't want
people stealing my information okay this
year's theme is do your part be cyber
smart getting cybersmart starts with
cyber hygiene that includes strong
passwords setting up multi-factor
authentication on your accounts
and regularly updating software on your
devices
it's very important to understand how
cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats for instance your
social security number for sale on the
dark web if they detect your information
lifelock will send you an alert no one
can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can keep what's yours
with lifelock identity theft protection
join right now save up to 25 off your
first year at lifelock.com
knowles kennedy wlas that is
dot
lifelock.com
slash knowles k-n-w-l-e-s for 25
off if i think of the word racist i
i guess what i
think of is that you hate someone on the
basis of their race
that's what i would say
it's not i don't think it's just that
you
have preconceptions or judgments of
people on the basis of race everybody
does that
hey think of an italian guy
think of an italian guy right now what
are you thinking of you're thinking of a
guy with a mustache who says hey it's
samia and you're thinking of pizza and
you're thinking of a loud argument with
his family at christmas and you think i
don't know you're thinking of you have
certain ideas hey think of an irishman
you're going to have some preconceptions
of what an irishman is you're probably
picturing a little leprechaun right now
with a pint of guinness or something and
saying hey they all be after me lucky
charms right that's that would be a
preconception but i don't think that's
racist
hey picture a chinese guy
what you're going to pick at least you
are picturing what he looks like was
that a pre is that a prejudgment a
prejudice a preconception well sure i
don't think it's racist
if you say i hate black people i guess
that i guess that that would be racist
right or i hate
the irish or something like that i hate
white people that certainly is racist
but the left tells us that's not racist
and now we're told
that any time you say anything
positive or negative or neutral about a
protected
group
you are a racist
and anytime you say anything vicious or
hateful about a non-protected group
like
white people or asian people that's
you're totally that's totally fine
that's not a big deal
so the word doesn't mean anything an
insurrection right now i don't think
means anything
if blm defends our democracy and the
horn guy is an insurrectionist then if
cops just not taking an experimental
drug as an insurrection
then insurrection doesn't mean anything
anymore and it means you really ought to
reconsider some of what you
thought about january 6th
january's the great the worst attack in
american history
wasn't the senate building like bombed
in within the last five decades i seem
to recall that i remember reading that
there there have been multiple attacks
actually in the last century
that led to a lot of destruction
on
very furious senate and house buildings
but january's the horn guy
the the podium they took pelosi's
lectern okay that's not good
it's not good to steal somebody's
lectern it's not good to steal
sneakers it's not good to steal gucci
handbags it's not good to torch the
country coast to coast but so one of
them is our democracy though and it's
really good and the other
is an insurrection i don't think so i'm
so glad you liked that clip but stop
hold up
ring that bell
yeah please you have to okay they don't
want you youtube does not want you to
get the notifications all the time okay
ring the bell subscribe head on over to
the michael knowles show at apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your podcasts
type it in
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-k-w-l-e-s s-h-o-w
fury
subscribe we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you